i think that on campuses buildings teach
i think they teach the students
subliminally about the value of place
and architecture and craft and this
building would be a great representation
of that
a building like this is a sensory
building the wood has its own aroma and
color and richness
it has light
it has its own sound and it already has
its own mythology
it has many stories to tell
it would be impossible to come in this
building spend time here and not
remember it
this building is a very iconic building
where it's situated close to the edge of
campus with its tower on the new haven
skyline it claims itself as a
destination
the humanities are about research in
balance with collaboration and in
balance with engagement with communities
of thinkers and enthusiasts
the concept here was of a unified
humanities environment
it would have been very difficult to
casually bump into somebody from another
department in the building the way it
was it wasn't a building that spoke to
collaboration and commonality these
departments are scattered some of them
were here but french and italian and
spanish was over on wall street above
the pizza place then if you wanted to go
to comp lit you had to go to 451 college
german was across the street you can't
build something whole when everything is
fragmented
you have to be able to bring the
fragments together we're very well known
for being a place of the humanities a
place that has a singular leadership
role in the humanities not only in the
united states but also around the world
bringing them together
into a single location is really an
opportunity to draw together in a
physical way the commitment we have
always had in a spiritual way the idea
of creating common ground in a building
that had been rather cellular so that
there was a flow in the building was one
of the challenges
this was an incredibly complex process
there's a lot of choreography between
understanding the end user's desires
working with the architect with design
aspirations working with the
construction manager for
constructability and putting that all
together
renovating a building is a lot more
challenging than building a new building
for me one of the most exciting things
was thinking how we could make it better
[Music]
there was always a desire to preserve
the architecture of this building it's
such an iconic building
james gamble rogers did many of the
buildings on campus and there's an
expectation of ornamentation and detail
that people expect when they come into
yale buildings
the idea of a larger footprint became
very appealing because it could offer us
the structural spans to support the big
collaborative and instructional spaces
without having to tear apart a valued
historic building we put in 12 000
square feet of underground space that
never existed before and there's a
state-of-the-art lecture hall and film
screening room down there we have a
courtyard that's really a roof now for
another building the fact that we had to
construct below the water table and
underpin the foundations for the entire
perimeter of the courtyard including a
15-story tower we had to dig down 30
feet dug out 30 000 cubic yards of soil
those are just mind-boggling exercises
of themselves
the entry sequence into this building is
very grand you have these beautiful
brick arches that welcome you right away
you can go left or right and be in a
light hallway now that is adorned with
offices and classroom space
the building brings together 15
different departments and programs near
eastern languages and civilizations sits
on a floor with directed studies film
and media studies sits adjacent to our
department of italian language and
literature history is now co-located
with units that study the literary
traditions in each of the regions of the
world i can work with professors and do
the lectures that they bring in work
with grad students
we took many existing corridors and we
actually widened them
we created spaces where people could sit
down have a cup of coffee see some
people these are connective spaces and
they're intended to be used in a very
fluid way
now they have lots of small little rooms
for conferences that we can immediately
just grab another professor move into a
room and talk and widen out the
conversation
you have an access to the tower which in
itself has a beautiful lobby swenson
tower will be home to graduate students
from across a range of departments
the new stair that connects the entrance
foyer to the lowest two levels required
complete structural rethink of that part
of the building it's designed
to invite people
when i walk through the building now
it's so easy to imagine how a great
lecture could be given in the lower
level lecture hall and you walk out with
someone that you're sitting next to and
have a conversation in the beautiful
reception space right outside that
lecture hall maybe you decide there
that'd be great to continue that
conversation in your offices which are
only two floors away
i think we always strive to bring people
together in ways that they don't expect
and
this project specifically will do that
we're going to have a lot more
interaction among the faculty and
hopefully for the students they will
develop interests that they didn't plan
to develop along the way
[Music]
now this building is a building that
speaks to not only the need for privacy
and individual research but also the
opportunity for the chance to encounter
the collaboration and bringing people
together
yale would be the first to admit that it
hadn't seen much updating or improvement
in many decades if you look at the plan
of the building it's a complex plan the
whole basement level which is now the
concourse was loaded with steam piping
so we had to be very creative about how
to route everything behind the beautiful
architecture we've probably never met a
building before
that had such resistance to upgrade
in its structural
composition
there was also the challenge of making
the building fully ada compliant fully
accessible
that is a big deal and to try to do that
in a way that's very sensitive to the
architecture is very challenging as well
in order to
restore a lot of the detail in this
building we did rely on really good
crafts people many of them local
we replaced all the windows
we salvaged 284 panels of art glass most
of the millwork was carefully restored
we had a local vendor restoring all the
iron work
all of the historic lighting was sent
out to be refurbished with energy
efficient led and then there's quite a
lot of new lighting to supplement that
this didn't just happen
this was planned
monitored and executed in ways that took
time and care and work
structurals mechanicals civil lighting
designers landscape architect you know
there was a cast of thousands hundreds
and hundreds of unique individuals
worked
on this particular project
a lot of our local new haven residents
to add it up we say it's 630 000 hours
went into the renovation of this
building by a wide variety of people
you pull these things off because you
have people who just never give up and
that tenacity is part of the success
story of this project if there's one
thing i'm most proud of it's how well we
worked as a team
i hope that this building will say
something about optimizing existing
conditions in ways that are innovative
there's the historic nature of the
building from ground floor up and then
there's a much more modern intervention
from concourse level down and i hope
it'll say something about making a
building that's available to everybody
who uses it by the way that it's
organized it's james gamble rogers 2.0
if you will it's a 21st century building
now i hope the students really
understand the value of the humanities
through this building
when you walk into it you can't help but
feel inspired of what could be possible
that we as a university decided to take
one of our central iconic campus
buildings to rebuild the space in ways
that encouraged collaboration in the
humanities is a signal to the world that
we are committed to this area of
excellence
[Music]